como lo habíamos comentado el secretario
de estado de Estados Unidos Anthony
blinken llegará este lunes a Jerusalén
en medio del escalamiento de la
violencia que comenzó la semana anterior
y es que todo empezó con el operativo
del ejército israelí en la ciudad
ocupada de llenín la incursión más letal
de los últimos años que ya deja diez
palestinos muertos al día siguiente un
palestino mató a siete israelíes A las
afueras de una sinagoga en Jerusalén y
luego un adolescente palestino de 13
años le disparó a dos personas a las
afueras de la ciudad vieja para entender
todo lo que estaba ocurriendo nos
comunicamos a esta hora con Pascal
analista político y especialista en
relaciones internacionales Pascal
Gracias por estar con nosotros y
bienvenido aquí a France 24 en español
Estados Unidos impulsa por ejemplo la
solución de los dos estados pero al
mismo tiempo no reconoce los territorios
palestinos como un estado Qué tan real
Entonces es que se alcance esa política
y no puede influir la visita de blinken
definitivamente esa base política
también es la de ropa esa voluntad de
trabajar para que un día estemos en un
esquema de dos estados pero por cierto
esa visita de Anthony blinquen se
inscribe muy bien lo dijo en este
momento de tensión muy grande desde el
fin de semana pasado y tenemos que
pensar obviamente en las familias de las
víctimas hubo un ataque en Jerusalén uno
de los más violentos y que pone en
relieve Pues esa violencia
en los territorios tanto como en en
Israel la visita de de blinquen no tenía
que ver con ese contexto Anthony
blinquen está hoy en día en Egipto se
reunió con el presidente al Sisi de ahí
viene obviamente a Jerusalén y va a ir a
ramala también verá más mudadas además
obviamente de Primer Ministro israelí
pero se inscribe en ese marco de tensión
ahora este también se inscribe en un
contexto muy particular benyamine taniau
ya es Primer Ministro desde el final del
mes de diciembre y pasado apenas volvió
al poder con una coalición una
globalición que los observadores
califican como de las más dura extrema
en la historia del Estado Israel es
decir que él cumple Pues con un programa
que presentó y con el cual pudo tener
una mayoría de coalición tomando en
cuenta que tiene aliados Sí Dentro de
los cuales el partido
que es el el más extremista con itamar
VIP que es el ministro de seguridad es
decir que estamos en ese momento en ese
contexto y además para concluir en un
contexto internacional
en el cual Finalmente y es una pregunta
aparecía reía clave
la situación en esta parte del mundo
cuando estamos con esa Guerra de Ucrania
entonces en eso está y como usted lo
mencionó el de Benjamín netanyahu ha
sido criticado por analistas como el más
ultraderechista de la historia de Israel
en ese contexto digamos Qué está
haciendo el gobierno de Joe biden
especialmente diferente al gobierno
pasado de Donald Trump recordemos que
Donald Trump cambió la embajada
estadounidense de Israel que antes
estaba entre la VIP y la movió a
Jerusalén que eso es una ciudad que se
disputan tanto israelíes como palestinos
y la consideran propia Y aunque biden
prometió cambios todavía no ha movido la
embajada Cómo es Entonces esta relación
de biden sobre todo con el nuevo
gobierno ultraderechista de netanyahu sí
Bueno creo que de otra manera la alianza
con Israel es una base muy importante y
una base para los Estados Unidos
apenas tres días hubo unas operaciones
militares de
experimentación en mediterráneo Oriental
juniter OK Que reunió a doce barcos
Israel y norteamericanos y a más de ocho
mil soldados de ambos países es decir
que esa Alianza está escrita ahora por
cierto yo Byron y lo dijo en el mes de
diciembre pasado dijo que iba a
desmotivar las políticas que podrían
poner en tela de juicio la viabilidad de
la solución de dos estados es decir pues
que sí hay evolución
evolución sobre unos temas de una
tonalidad política pero definitivamente
la alianza Ahí está ahora ojo estamos
también Pues en un marco regional muy
importante
usted hizo y lo hizo también una
referencia Pues a reconocimiento de
Jerusalén por el expresidente Donald
Trump pero también pues los acuerdos de
Abraham en 2020 repusieron una un nuevo
contexto regional ya abriendo esas
relaciones entre Israel
Israel los emiratos árabes Unidos es
decir pues que hay un contexto
Obviamente con una sombra una sombra de
peligro que es el nuclear
iraní la proliferación nuclear y raní
acordese que acaba de haber un ataque en
un en una planta militar y raní cerca de
hispan por drons todo eso pues es el
contexto en el cual se inscribe esa
visita y el esa ola de violencia desde
varios días y como usted menciona
Estados Unidos dice que pondrá en tela
de juicio todas las políticas israelíes
que no contribuyan a una solución de los
estados que significa básicamente que se
reconozca tanto los territorios
palestinos como Israel como estados
distintos pero benjamina tanyahu anunció
medidas que podrían ir en contra de esta
solución de los dos estados por ejemplo
ampliar la posibilidad de que los
israelíes se armen o tener medidas más
fuertes contra las familias de los
palestinos que cometan ataques como
quitarles la seguridad social y
quitarles Incluso el permiso de
residencia Cómo entender entonces estas
acciones de netanyahu
Sí bueno él como dije cumple con un
programa sobre el cual ha sido elegido
al final del año pasado hace parte de un
programa que presentó y está Pues con
sus aliados políticos cumpliendo con esa
con esa ese eje político ahora Anthony
blinker llega en este momento Y por
cierto el margen de maniobra es muy
estrecho para los Estados Unidos pero
lograr en estabilizar la situación sería
ya un éxito para esa visita la cuarta de
Anthony vinquen en Israel y en medio
oriente